Let me ask you a question: Which do you prefer:
the country or the city?
Ok, I’m sure your answer will depend on
what activity you have in mind.
If we want to spend a few days away from the
hustle and bustle of the city, we’d probably
choose the countryside,
but if instead we think about day-to-day life,
undertaking our own business projects or going
on a night out, the answer may change completely…
Don’t fool yourself.
We all like cities.
And that has consequences.
For the first time ever in history, more than
half of the world's population lives in cities.
Cities have emerged as the nuclei in which
people, completely unknown to each other and
of various origins, coexist and coordinate
their lives to fulfill their goals.
Who hasn’t felt amazed by the hustle and
bustle of London, New York or Tokyo?
A huge mix of cultures, religions and nationalities.
Cities are made up of very different people,
but many have something in common: the desire
to grow as a society.
Isn’t that amazing?
Without thinking about it, or in many cases
without even being aware of it, we contribute
to the welfare of a lot of people we don’t
even know, and they do the same in return,
by providing a lot of services that we need.
It is precisely for this reason, folks, that
cities have been consolidated as the axis,
the nucleus, the engine of the freest and
most prosperous human society model that humanity
has ever known.
But does the growth of cities today pose a
threat to the rural world?
Are cities meeting the needs of their residents?
How is global urbanization affecting people’s
lives?
Let's take a look!
(FROM THE COUNTRYSIDE TO THE CITY)
I’m sure many of you have grandparents or
great-grandparents who were born and lived
in a village.
Because, folks, the migration from the countryside
to the city has been a relatively recent phenomenon.
You all know this, historically, humans lived
scattered in small communities where life
was based on subsistence farming and whatever
products they were able to produce.
If you were lucky, you might have your own
plot of land, where you’d raise a few animals
and plant vegetables, which you’d later
consume.
As you can imagine, life was very, very hard.
People spent their lives working from childhood
to try to get ahead, often with no chance
of ever securing a better life.
And, what’s more, the risk of external factors
making life worse was extremely high.
For example, drought or flood could lead to
a terrible famine that could end the lives
of thousands and thousands of people.
Not to mention wars, invasion and disease.
That’s why, among other things, mortality
was so high in the past.
So, would you like to go back to the good
old days?
Surely not...
Come on, don’t kid yourself, in 99% of cases,
the answer will be no.
In general, cities offer us a higher quality
of life and a range of opportunities.
It all began with industrialization, back
in the eighteenth and nineteenth centuries,
which also lead to a boom in trade and technological
innovations.
In that era, cities began to grow exponentially,
by attracting millions of people from the
countryside who wanted to improve their living
conditions.
And that's the definition of urbanization,
the massive transfer of people from the countryside
to the city that has been happening continuously
for more than two centuries.
A process that has allowed many completely
new economic activities to flourish, improving
everyone's lives.
Since as recent as 1960, the world’s urban
population has multiplied by four, while the
rural population has grown very slowly, and
has almost reached tipping point.
It’s estimated that between 2025 and 2030
the world's rural population will begin to
shrink for the first time in the history of
mankind.
So far it has decreased in relative terms,
but now it’ll also begin to do so in absolute
terms.
Basically, we live in a world of cities.
Now, how may this change affect us?
Obviously, in order to live, we need goods
produced in the countryside, in particular
food.
And this leads us to a big question that comes
up every once in a while:
Can a world of cities feed the planet’s
growing population?
Does this urbanization process threaten our
food security?
Hmmm...
A lot of people say yes, but we’re not so
sure about it.
Folks, a question we need to ask ourselves
is, are we producing food in the same way
as we did 50 years ago?
The short answer is no, we’re not.
Nowadays we don’t need 10, 20, or 30 farmers
to plough a couple of hectares of land, a
John Deere 8285R is more than enough.
This has a name: mechanization.
The new technologies, which, incidentally,
tend to be developed in the cities, have brought
tremendous improvements to the rural environment,
improvements that of course translate into
a better quality of life.
In the countryside, mechanization has greatly
reduced the number of workers required in
the field, not only maintaining but even increasing
agricultural production.
That’s exactly why Malthusian theories,
the theories that claim that the world is
suffering from overpopulation and that we
won’t have the resources to feed everyone,
fail over and over and over again.
However, hold on a second folks, because as
you can imagine, this population explosion
creates many, many challenges in the cities,
especially in developing countries.
The main one is urban poverty, caused among
other things by the scarcity of housing that
occurs in extreme cases of urban explosion,
which we’ll take a closer look at in a moment.
But despite these challenges and problems,
have you ever wondered, what exactly is the
big attraction that cities offer that lead
so many people to move to them?
Well...
Listen up.
(CITIES, COOPERATION HUBS)
Why did industrialization emerge in cities?
Why are the head offices of major companies
always in the largest cities?
It’s not only about having access to better
infrastructure, such as roads, ports or airports,
but also about having easy access to all of
us, that is, to human resources.
Folks, companies need a lot of different profiles,
different people, to be able to function.
Have you ever wondered how many people are
involved in the creation of just one everyday
product?
Say for example, a car.
You need engineers, mechanics, designers,
even leather tanners and artisans for the
vehicle’s interior details.
That’s precisely why the biggest cities,
where more people of different profiles coexist,
are the ideal place to find human resources.
The more professionals and different profiles
there are, the more attractive the place will
be.
Cities have become true hubs of human cooperation,
where we fill the needs of others, and they,
in turn, supply us with what we lack.
All this without even knowing us, isn’t
that incredible?
These hubs of businesses, entrepreneurship
and consumers have triggered economic growth.
Now, at this point there’s a question we
need to ask ourselves here on VisualPolitik:
Where is this phenomenon happening most markedly?
Do you know?
I’m sure it won’t surprise you.
Yes, exactly, in Asia.
But... hold on, because Africa is already
catching up.
Yes, Africa!
And, folks, this is hardly surprising.
Since the beginning of urbanization, the income
per capita for the most urbanized Asian countries
has skyrocketed.
Urbanization is directly related to economic
development.
The great amount of knowledge, goods and services
exchanges that take place in cities, was something
unknown to mankind until very recently.
They’re something of a modern miracle.
Asian countries that have experienced greater
migrations from the countryside to the city
have seen their citizens’ per capita income
skyrocket.
That’s the case in South Korea, Thailand,
Japan and Malaysia, among others.
Check out this chart.
The greater the concentration of inhabitants,
the higher the country’s per capita income.
And the variation in just 10 years, between
2000 and 2010, leaves no room for doubt.
But, these aren’t isolated cases.
This phenomenon has extended throughout the
developed world.
Western Europe, for example, was by far the
first part of the world to experience urbanization,
doubling and even tripling the rates of urbanization
found in the rest of the world.
In other words, to a large extent, the old
continent’s success can be attributed to
its pioneering bet on city models.
In fact, with this data in hand, the first
thing that may come to mind is how it is surprising
that it took so long for the other regions
to join this phenomenon, and yet achieve similar
results so quickly.
And it's not just an economic issue.
Not at all!
Science, culture, and political freedoms have
almost always originated in cities.
Cooperation between human beings is easier
and simpler in these spaces, making it easier
for creativity, serendipity and influential
political movements to emerge.
And of course, this is no surprise.
In a village being different or thinking differently
can make you an outcast.
In cities you become one more, part of an
artistic, intellectual or political movement.
It's that simple.
Now, hold on just a second.
How can we accommodate millions of rural people
in cities without having the necessary housing,
infrastructure and services?
In India, they know a bit about this challenge.
(INDIA, EXPLOSIVE URBANIZATION)
Folks, we’ve already talked about this here
on VisualPolitik.
India is starting to become a manufacturing
power.
It’s beginning to take its first steps towards
becoming China’s competitor.
For example, Apple has already announced that
it’ll stop manufacturing the new iPhone
in China, to do it in India instead.
Incredible, right?
Foxconn Is Said Close to Trial Output of Newest
iPhones in India.
Bloomberg
And of course, India’s industrialization
will require a lot of workers, people who
are arriving en masse from the countryside
to the cities.
The urbanization phenomenon is happening so
rapidly, that in India and in many other cities
of the developing world, guaranteeing access
to basic services such as electricity, running
water, education, health and infrastructure
is posing gigantic problems, as it requires
huge investment.
And this investment, folks, poses quite a
challenge in some countries.
For example, Delhi gets around 700,000 new
residents every year, and already has more
than 27 million inhabitants in its metropolitan
area.
Its growth is so astronomical that by 2028
it could become the largest megacity in the
world, surpassing even Tokyo.
But just a second…
How can homes for 700,000 people be built
in a single year?
And what’s more, how can it be done year
after year?
In India, urbanization is happening very quickly,
and this entails difficulties in guaranteeing
access to housing for all the people arriving
in the city.
Due to this, it’s estimated that 24% of
the urban population lives in shanty towns
without even the most basic living conditions.
Basically, to accommodate all of Delhi’s
new inhabitants, you’d need to build between
700 and 900 million square meters every year.
That works out to something roughly the size
of Chicago each year.
Is this even possible?
It seems like a complicated challenge…
And unfortunately, many newcomers are forced
to live in shanty towns, better known as "slums".
In Lalbagh, the largest slum in Delhi, more
than 300,000 people live in a single square
kilometer.
Quite horrific.
Despite the Indian Government’s efforts
to build houses to relocate the poorest, the
challenge is so huge that it’s like fighting
against the clock to reduce something that
doesn’t stop growing.
How will India deal with this problem?
We'll talk about this in a later video, here,
on VisualPolitik.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.